so I'm not going to comply with this
mask order in Los Angeles it this is
arbitrary it has no bearing on reality
I'm just not going to do it okay I'm
there's a very famous short story a lot
of kids read it in school it's called
bartleby the scrivener by Herman
Melville the guy wrote Moby Dick and in
it you know there's this guy Bartleby
and Bartleby is working at this office
and whenever he's told to do something
he just says I would prefer not to he
just you can say that to your boss hey
go go right up this thing go do this
thing I would prefer not to that's how I
feel about this order we got another we
got another piece of news from Los
Angeles yesterday remember we covered
these arbitrary public health rulings so
they've told us now they've heard us
they say the beaches are open but for
active use only no passive use on the
beach face coverings are required when
you're sitting on the beach so you can
see you're gonna get a very awkward tan
line because this bottom part of your
faces will be very pale and the upper
part is going to be tan you must
maintain six feet of distance from
others if it's five feet 11 inches you
will get coronavirus but six feet and 1
inch you'll be good
you were permitted on the beach to swim
surf body board run and walk maybe not
jogging jogging might be up in the air
but you are not permitted it is
prohibited for you to sit or sunbathe or
play volleyball or picnic you can't
picnic or bike you can run but you can't
bike you can surf but you can't bike you
can walk but you can't sit and you can't
sunbathe even though some preliminary
evidence shows that vitamin D is a very
good way to fight off coronavirus but
that I don't know they don't want you to
get too much Sun too much vitamin D it's
just it's absurd obviously I feel like
Nancy Pelosi at the State of the Union
it's it's arbitrary is the problem and
arbitrary power grabs are not what we're
about in this country we like the rules
to be clear we have a country that is
based on a constitution that builds up
in that builds
institutions that then pass laws for us
and govern us not the whims of some
two-bit tin-pot dictator
[Music]
[Music]